bond villains are both essential and
complex they need to be interestingly
twisted
memorably designed and powerful enough
to square off with the world's
undisputed king of espionage there have
been
many worthy adversaries over the years
so let's get to work
exploring the last words of every major
fallen bond villain
julia snow played by joseph wiseman was
the first bond villain
debuting in 1962's dr no this film
established
several trends for bond villains chief
among them
the sinister secret lair in no's case he
has an underground facility which boasts
equipment capable of jamming american
missile launches
his radio beam is powered by a nuclear
reactor
at the climax of the film bond
infiltrates his lair and destroys the
equipment by overloading it
referring to the reactor dr noe shouts
his final words at his workers
bond and no wrestle on a small metal
elevator as it descends into a vat of
boiling liquid
luckily bond gets the upper hand and no
melts into nothingness in from russia
with love
bond foils the evil plans of rosa cleb
played by lottie lenya
cleb is a high-ranking member of
russia's counterintelligence agency
secretly she's also part of the sinister
organization known as spectre
cleb wants to take revenge on bond for
dr noe's death
and also seeks to steal a decoding
device in the process
after bond secures the decoding device
he goes on vacation with tatiana
romanova to celebrate his victory but
surprise surprise cleb makes one last
effort to slay bond
club disguises herself as a maid at the
hotel bond is staying at
when bond and romanova order room
service it's delivered by a gun-wielding
club
cleb orders robinova to take the
decoding device and delivers her final
words
take this presumably cleb was going to
follow her at gunpoint but it never
happens because a fight breaks out
while bond and klebs struggle romanova
finds a gun
and shoots cleb dead orrick goldfinger
played by gert fruba
hails obviously from the film goldfinger
his greed drives him to assemble a small
militia and assault fort knox
bond foils that planned and goldfinger
goes home
empty-handed but he's still a little
peeved at bond
the white house invites bond to eat with
the president so
bond hops on a plane but the ever clever
or goldfinger sneaks aboard as well
dressed as military personnel goldfinger
reveals himself and points a gun at bond
initially bond is surprised but he
quickly comes up with a plan
bond asks an innocent question about
where [ __ ] galore is
as though he's deeply concerned
goldfinger answers
she's where she ought to be at the
controls
at this bond surprises goldfinger by
tackling him
while struggling the gun accidentally
fires shooting out an airplane window
goldfinger gets sucked out and that's
the last we see
the gold obsessed villain to be honest
these final words are pretty bland as
far as bond villains go
emilio largo thunderball's bad guy is
the bond villain with the unforgettable
eye patch
largo plans to steal nuclear weapons and
extort world governments by threatening
to use them
the last major fight in the film is a
high-speed boat chase
largo is sailing away firing at the
authorities behind him
during the chaos bond subtly boards
largo's boat
and ambushes his crew when bond finally
reveals himself
largo shouts at his henchmen
the henchmen do their thing they swing
miss
and die finally bond and largo face each
other but it isn't bond who delivers the
final blow
that honor goes to domino largo's
mistress who shoots him in the back with
a harpoon
like so many bond villains dr kaninga
played by yafet kodo wants to kill bond
in an
unnecessarily elaborate way and live and
let die
but dr kaninga is uniquely twisted even
among his adversary alumni
dr koninga captures bond and solitaire
in his underground lair
then ties them up to be lowered into a
pool of sharks
but being the sadistic monster that he
is
he wants it to happen slowly dr
kaninga's henchman
whisper is at the controls after opening
the gate to allow the sharks in
whisper begins lowering bond and
solitaire towards their toothy doom
that's when dr kaninga instructs whisper
slowly whisper slowly slowly
let out diners assemble little does
kanenga know
bond has a nifty gadget disguised as a
wrist watch
which helps him escape in the ensuing
struggle bond
shoves an explosive gas pellet into
kananga's mouth resulting in one of the
most
over-the-top villain deaths in the
franchise
it's amazing how much time there is
between francisco scaramonga's final
words
and his death in the man with the golden
gun skara manga played by christopher
lee is a talented assassin who wishes to
dual bond to the death
in skara manga's mind it's not about
killing bond
it's about defeating a worthy opponent
so instead of killing bond when he has
the chance
skara manga arranges a duel on his
island both men have their backs to each
other
with their signature guns in hand
scaramonga with his golden pistol
and bond with his walter ppk
skaramonga's henchman serves as a
referee of sorts
and asks both duelers if they are ready
to which both reply
ready
ready the henchman counts down
the men take 20 paces but when bond
turns and shoots
skara manga is gone bond and skara manga
play cat and mouse throughout the island
and then inside a maze of illusions
skara manga knows his way around
and bond does not still bonds surprises
garamonga and shoots him dead
carl stromberg played by kurt jurgens
spends most of the spy who loved me's
run time
trying to incite nuclear war during
which he will be under the sea
in his atlantis-like palace he then
plans to repopulate the world but this
time
civilization will happen entirely
underwater
bond sabotages stromberg's plan but is
then tasked with rescuing his love
interest amasova from stromberg's
clutches
after infiltrating his underwater lair
bond finds stromberg sitting alone at a
long dinner table
they exchange words as bond slowly takes
his seat
his gun pointed at stromberg at all
times
little does bond know that stromberg has
one last trick up his sleeve
a long gun underneath the table that
points
right at the seat where bond is sitting
bond tells him that his time is running
out
stromberg responds too mr bund
you as too and faster than you think
stromberg pulls the trigger but bond
gets out of the way in time and shoots
stromberg to death
the rich and sophisticated hugo drax
played by michael lonsdale and moonraker
is a businessman who builds spacecrafts
secretly
however he plans to start humanity over
drax's scheme is to poison the entire
earth
then orbit the planet with a few
selected humans he considers to be the
quote master race once the gas settles
he'll repopulate earth with his chosen
few
bond foils his plan and finally corners
tracks on his space station
for a brief moment drax gets the upper
hand
he spots a gun on the floor quickly
picks it up and points at a bond
just as he's about to shoot drax says
at least i shall have the pleasure of
putting you out of my misery
isolated mr bomb but at that
moment bond makes his place shooting
drax and ejecting him into outer space
safe travels space hitler the death of
blofeld
is a tad complicated so stick with us
for a moment
in the original bond continuity blofeld
appears in several films as the main
villain of the series
blofeld has a few fake deaths but bond
finally kills blofeld for good in
diamonds or forever
or so we thought legal battles
complicated the bond franchise including
a debate over who owned
the character of blofeld in 1981 for
your eyes only
came out in the introduction bond kills
an unnamed character played by john
hollis who bears a
striking resemblance to blofeld the
villain is never
called blofeld for copyright reasons but
viewers are
clearly supposed to conclude that it's
him blofeld who is now using a
wheelchair
is trying to assassinate bond but bond
turns the tables
using a helicopter bond picks up blofeld
and drops him down
an industrial chimney blofeld begs for
his life before dying
shouting
since that time the bond series has been
rebooted with daniel craig as double07
in this second continuity the new
blofeld is played by christoph waltz and
is still alive played by julian glover
in
for your eyes only aristotle christados
nicknamed
aris is a loathsome fellow the british
government awarded him an
honor for his service in the war but
during that time arus was actually a
double agent
on top of that he's a huge heroin
smuggler
oh and did we mention he also tried
tricking bond into killing colombo who
used to be arys's business partner
arys's evil plan is to steal a valuable
device from the british military and
sell it to the soviets
bond ends up joining forces with colombo
and tracking down
aris to his hideout arys gives one last
command to his niece bb doll
after a fight he yells at her go back to
your room you could go to hell
but soon after bond begins his assault
as good guys and bad guys beat each
other up
ares makes a run for it eventually they
catch up
and columbo deals the final blow by
throwing a knife into arya's back
killing him kamal khan played by louis
jordan
in octopus he is often ranked as one of
the worst bond villains of all time
khan is an exiled afghan prince who gets
involved in all kinds of illegal
activities
he allies himself with general orlov and
plans to unleash a nuclear weapon in
europe
to finance their operation they sell
fake jewelry their plan fails so
khan flees using his personal airplane
bond pursues him
and in the air khan realizes bond is on
top of his plane so
khan does the only logical thing for a
villain to do he tells his henchmen to
go out there and kill bond
the henchman is naturally reluctant so
khan forces him to go by saying
go out and get him out there
bond kills the henchmen of course
meanwhile khan does some crazy flying to
throw bond off
while close to the ground bond disables
an engine and jumps to the ground
khan then nose dives to his death
general orlov played by steven burkhoff
and octopussy is a soviet military man
who would love
nothing more than to expand the glorious
power of his motherland he's basically
a bloodthirsty warmonger and a bit
delusional as well
orlov's plan is to sneak a bomb into
europe on a train
he hopes to set off a nuke which will
force europe to disarm their nuclear
weapons
allowing the soviets to expand into
europe
bond boards the train and orolov chases
after him
in an ironic twist of fate the nearby
guards shoot orlov believing he's a
defector
a fellow soviet stands over orlov and
calls him quote
a disgrace to the uniform orlov while
bleeding to death
proclaims yes but tomorrow
i shall be a hero of the soviet
union as with certain other bond
villains max zorin's final words consist
of him
fruitlessly ordering his henchmen to
kill bond zorin played by christopher
walken in a view to a kill
is a successful businessman who runs
company that builds microchips
zorin's evil plan is to sink silicon
valley into the ocean
eliminating all his competitors and
making his company the sole microchip
provider in the world
the climax of the film takes place on
top of the golden gate bridge where
zorin has anchored his blimp
bond climbs to the top of the bridge and
starts heading for the blimp
as soon as zorton realizes bond is up
there with him he tells his underlings
go get him
yo zorin then grabs an axe
and like a wild man starts swinging at a
bond
trying to knock him off the bridge bond
gets the upper hand
and zorin falls to his death brad
whitaker played by joe don baker in
the living daylights is a war obsessed
arms dealer although he's never
fought in war himself whitaker's plan is
to obtain and sell a large amount of
opium so that he can deal
arms far into the future at his base
whitaker has a room
full of various figures statues maps and
army toys this is where whitaker and
bond have their final battle
playing a game of cat and mouse through
the elaborate room
whitaker naturally has the upper hand
since he's on familiar turf
he activates various traps with a remote
and throws bond off his game
but the room is large dark and very
complicated so
bond has quite a few hiding spots bond
places a small bomb
and lures whitaker towards it meanwhile
whitaker scolds bond for hiding behind a
particular statue
should have known you take refuge behind
that british vulture wellington
you know he had to buy german
mercenaries to beat napoleon
in response bond activates his bomb
which knocks over a statue
and kills whitaker franz sanchez played
by robert davey in license to kill
is a terrifying bond villain sanchez's
evil plot is to mass produce drugs and
basically
kill and or corrupt anyone who gets in
his way
he's not the kind of guy you want to
mess with
in their final showdown sanchez and bond
are going head-to-head in the middle of
a desert
sanchez is pretty angry since bond just
took out several of his men
and destroyed multiple tankers
containing cocaine
essentially bond sabotaged sanchez's
whole operation
after wrecking in the desert sanchez
gets soaked in gas
and wields a machete against bond he's
perplexed as to why bond does not wish
to be rich
like him you could have had everything
don't you want to know why
bond pulls out a lighter and shows it to
a curious sanchez
just then bond ignites the lighter
burning
sanchez alive if you've watched
goldeneye you already know
this final line carries a lot of meaning
alec trevlin played by sean bean used to
work alongside bond as a fellow mi6 spy
trevlin ended up faking his death then
went on to betray
mi6 and attempt to destroy the
organization
so not only does bond have to kill a
villain in this movie
he also has to kill a friend before
faking his death
trevlin asked bond
meaning the two heroes were about to do
what they were going to do for their
country
years later bond and travelling face
each other again and
trevlin realizes that he's about to die
for real
but trevlin wants to know why bond is
killing him and so he asks
for england james in other words bond
isn't being a patriots at this moment
he's avenging his own betrayal
travelin falls briefly survives and is
finally crushed by a giant satellite
that falls on top of him why do villains
always have to taunt their victims
before killing them
they give these long speeches and
throats ridiculous threats
which only serve to give the hero time
to cook up a plan to kill them
or get out of their clutches eliot
carver played by jonathan price and
tomorrow never dies
is no exception to this rule carver owns
a broadcasting empire
and his evil plan is to incite a war
between china and england
to secure exclusive broadcasting rights
in china
bond of course intervenes but at one
point carver has bond at his mercy
naturally carver goes on to brag that
his plan will prevail
he explains that he will successfully
orchestrate a plan in which the british
navy will destroy a submarine
and that he will even be covering the
event he gleefully says
it's going to be a fantastic show
but while he's on his high horse bond
secretly presses a button
that sends a moving blade towards carver
carver hears the sound and turns around
but it's too late bond grabs carver and
shoves him into a gruesome death
carver does scream as he dies
victor renard zokus played by robert
carlisle is one of two villains in the
world is not enough
renard is helping his accomplice elektra
king in her quest to cause a nuclear
meltdown in istanbul using a submarine
theirs is a long story containing many
twists and turns
originally renard kidnapped elektra but
the two eventually became lovers and
accomplices
bond kills elektra then boards the
submarine that renard is using to carry
out
his evil plan renard is an especially
tough villain to take down he can't feel
pain due to a bullet lodged in his head
but that doesn't mean renard is immune
to
emotional pain while fighting bond loses
the advantage
and so he throws renard off his game by
telling him that elektra is dead
bernard says
[Music]
he then shoves bond away and continues
to carry out his plan to detonate the
submarine
even though this means they'll both die
in its explosion
but of course bond saves the day renard
is impaled by a rod shot from the
submarine's reactor at high speed
in addition to renard the other villain
in the world is not enough
is electra king played by sophie marco a
seductive and devious businesswoman
king wants to cause a nuclear meltdown
in istanbul the result would give her
business a monopoly on crude oil king
plans to use her accomplice renard to
man the submarine that will detonate the
explosion
bond finds king alone and threatens to
kill her if she continues with her plan
king is holding a walkie-talkie and is
considering communicating with renard
telling him to proceed with their plans
bond explains that he will kill king if
she tries to talk with renard
but king isn't buying it she playfully
tells bond
you wouldn't
yes die
bond immediately shoots her dead then
dishes out a punny
ice cold retort i never miss
gustav graves played by toby stevens and
willian lee in
die another day is a man of grandeur who
is prone to making
epic speeches he also has a crazy
backstory
originally he was a north korean arms
dealer but he fakes his death
alters his appearance and resurfaces as
the british
billionaire if that wasn't wild enough
for you
graves builds a space weapon and plans
to use it to cut through the
demilitarized zone between north and
south korea provoking a war
bond sabotages graves's plan and the
film
culminates on a traveling aircraft where
graves and bond
duke it out graves gains the advantage
and
like all classic villains gives bond a
lecture before delivering the death blow
full of self-importance graves tells
bond
you can't kill my dreams but my dreams
can kill you
time to face destiny at that moment bond
quickly pulls the parachute cord
attached to graves which sucks graves
out of the airplane and right into a
turbine
the schiff played by mass mickelson in
casino royale
is an absolutely awesome bond villain le
chef has
quite a business going for himself he's
a banker
to terrorists he puts their money into
stocks which are then manipulated by
terrorist attacks
le chef isn't perfect however and gets
in over his head by losing a ton of
money
with some very bad people out to kill
him the schiff holds a high stakes poker
game to recoup his losses
but loses to bond which makes the shift
even more desperate
he kidnaps and tortures bond to get the
poker winnings but
right in the middle of his torture
session a man named mr white
walks in le chef assumes the man is
looking for money so he says
tell them i'll get the money but mr
white says he doesn't care about the
money
and just shoots le chief dead
[Music]
dominic greene played by matthieu
almerick in quantum of solace
is a very successful businessman and a
member of the secret organization known
as quantum
green's sinister plan is to collect
fresh water sources
create an artificial drought then profit
from selling water
specifically green wants to take
advantage of the bolivian government
if bolivia refuses to buy green's
expensive water
he plans to deprive them of water
entirely
bond locates green's complex and
single-handedly eliminates green
security detail
after capturing green bond interrogates
him but not so much about the water
scheme
bond is much more interested in the
organization that green works for
after bond extracts all the useful
information he can out of green
he leaves him in the middle of a desert
with a can of oil
green wants bond to spare him arguing i
told you what you wanted to know about
quantum
but bond drives off anyway it's later
reported that green was shot by an
assassin and apparently did try to drink
the oil before dying
a fitting fate for a man who threatened
to kill millions through dehydration
in skyfall raul silva played by javier
bardem
is a cyber terrorist who's out for
revenge on m
previously silva worked for mi6 but the
chinese government
found and tortured him silva blames em
so he's dedicated his life
to ruining hers the torture that silva
endured
left him physically scarred and mentally
deranged but his skills as a spy
remain he uses his abilities to kidnap
em and bring her to bond's childhood
home
there silva holds em close to himself
and puts a gun in her hand
with his hand on top of hers he points
the gun to both of their heads
wanting her to kill both of them silva
insists
that m pull the trigger saying only you
can do it
at that moment bond intervenes hurling a
knife into silva's back
he twists and turns but finally falls
dead
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more louver videos but
your favorite movie villains are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you